[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so I wrote a story and I'm
going to tell you about my story
so me and my browser so this is me I'm a
web developer I write code for work
that's what I get paid to do and
sometimes I feed that to a thing called
browser that's the box and then comes up
as a awesome sauce so when I started it
was like yes this is really interesting
so I learned so many other tools like
jQuery and act and then I figure out the
browser and browser he buys me back like
awesome web application you know and
then I got like used to it so like I'm
gonna learn more libraries I added on
top of jQuery and the act d3 right I fed
them and then suddenly browser became
unhappy I don't know why but I was told
that I need to learn my you know tools
so I added typescript and bubble to my
Taulbee and I sent it to a browser once
again and you know it's not quite
unhappy but it's like janky as hell so
at this point I'm like I don't like
browser like I don't know about you why
are you keeping distance from me
I just wanted to be friends with you
like the beginning I really liked
hanging out with you it was all a song
you know you write HTML put it into
browser don't even need a server
something moose amazing so I started
realized maybe it's me it's me that's
outside of the brother who is not
understanding and maybe what I need to
do is to understand what is inside so
when I was a kid so I grew up in Japan
there's a thing called papers theater or
Kamishibai which is exactly this you get
a stack of paper ordered there is a
story on the back there's gonna read a
picture and then you work through and
you know these are the things that you
would get
I don't know communal events or library
you know one of those days that somebody
needs to book for you instead of the
book it might be the box and I used to
love it both performing and being the
audience because the stories that they
tell inside of the paper theater box is
like classic like the stories that
everybody knows the story is the many
different paper sorry the the picture
books are written for kids but the
people who is producing the deck set for
paper theater intimately understood the
the nature of this simple sliding box
and sometimes on the back of the card
they have kind of like a direction of
how to perform them it's a slide halfway
the dis part and then slide it out so
they knew the environment and they knew
the stage and they fed the content that
it's best suited for the job if you can
switch to the slides so this was me
hello genius cool it's been amazing to
be back
I spoke three years ago when I spoke
three years ago this was me I
still beginning of my journey into doing
this development thing for work I always
worked in tech but not getting paid
writing code so I was trying to figure
this out and this is maybe me now-ish
the difference is that I now care about
my config files I care about what goes
into my build a pipeline but I don't
mean II mmm consider myself as a like a
expert web developer but since the three
years ago when I spark I got you know to
new job I guess and you know so I feel
like confident that I am progressing and
I am employable and I am doing this for
work speaking of work beginning of this
year I was assigned to a project with
three other engineers who I consider all
of them advanced than me they were the
one who is writing a UI framework they
were the one who is writing spec for
service workers and CSS they knew their
craft and you can imagine my
intimidation on writing a first poly
quest to them being under microscope of
the person who react and you were
writing UI so I felt this like divide a
between them and me not of the personal
divide about just the knowledge and the
level of conversation that they are
having if you go routine needing that
their level of accomplish you know that
they were having is that like oh I don't
want to use that CSS because it doesn't
transform whatever that means I don't
mean like like this API because it
doesn't use compositor whatever that
means they're gonna debate on like
whether to do the event delegation or
bubbling I'm like either way so I felt
like they knew the behind the scenes of
browser and they are making
sophisticated choice so I decided it's
time to join them going back on the
other side and then investigate what the
heck is going on inside
the browser so this talk I change the
talk title from the abstract so this is
the how to be a web master inside a look
at modern web browser and I called it
how to be a master because I consider
the person master or craftsman to be the
person who intimately knows their tools
in order to do their job there is a lot
of register to traditional masters in
Japan and all of them like I love
watching those documentaries all of them
intimately knows the craft and their
tools so my intent was that it by
understanding the to love my job browser
try to be a web master in order to go
into how browser internals I need to
cover a few of the computer concepts
before going to it because I promised
the organizers that this talk will be
nope no requirement for previous
knowledge so few concepts that I want to
talk about before go in it and then fair
warning I am making very very very
generalization of these concepts if you
disagree with me please tell me how you
think so the pool side tomorrow so the
first thing is a CPU sometimes called
central processing unit CPU is a
hardware on your computer that is really
good at doing a lot of computational
tasks they can handle a lot of things
but they can they do it one by one as
the tasks come as in the modern
computers case it is there that you only
have one core the worker for CPU you
usually have a few of them on your
computer so they're doing even more work
all together another concept is a GPU
graphics processing unit GPU also does
computations and can perform and there's
a core but GPU control into CPU is
really good at doing simple tasks all at
once with many many many more cores so
as the name suggests they were primarily
started to be used by a graphics card
and I'm putting the graphics on the
computer
my aim turning on and off the million
bits of the pixels in the computer but
they're gaining a lot more computational
power so accelerated GPU computing and
they can do a little more math basically
to do so but they do it fast all
together so you might see the machine or
the computer hardware the CPU and GPU
lives and your application not just web
application lives on top of them and CPU
and GPU is hunting whatever the logic
that you put into the application well
not quite
in between your application and machine
hardware there is usually a operating
system that is kind of facilitating
communications between them so in
Chrome's case - in order to put a
graphics on the screen clone publishes a
OpenGL command that sometimes on some
other platform just directly fed into
but on Windows that goes through a
conversion phase to convert it into like
X I think that is more suited for a
graphics on Windows so another concept
that I want to talk about is a process
and threat and I apologize in advance a
fairly abstract visualization contrôlée
- CPU and GPU but like process since the
roads are already abstract concept if
you look up from Hardware point of view
and on top of that like it doesn't make
any sense process what's process
visualize like the way it's like a lot
of people write like a literal threads
on the screen but like I don't know to
me it didn't click so just imagine the
process is a unit on CPU that is letting
your applications and the threads that's
inside of the process and thread is the
one actually executing that code for the
process so if you start a any
application the windows open up behind
the scenes of that UI is the CPU starts
a process process use memory so whatever
you do on the application
that gets saved into memory in the
meantime of you learning the application
and if you cool start application
process goes away then morning at 3:00
and then later for other operations the
process can also store a another process
to kind of like divide the work focus so
they start they use different location
of the memory and they walk together by
communicating single inter process
communication or sometimes a IPC and
good thing about this it's that if one
of the process gets hung up with
something the bug or something and then
just becomes unresponsible then you just
close it and then the original process
to live so your application might as
well still be in running with a few
blocking bits of UI while that other
process comes back up so what the
browser is process and threads look like
so one browser might look like this the
one giant process and many threads
inside or might look like this with a
few other processes and few threads
inside of them or it might look like
this many many more processes and kind
of like a divided work in fact this is
where Chrome's architecture is moving
towards now the idea is that each of the
tasks or service so that if you are
learning chrome on low powered device
member process takes up memory they can
consolidate them so that there is a less
process to provide the experience but if
you were on Mac or something that is
powerful then they can spin up more
processes to do a better efficient work
so for the purpose of the talk I'm going
to talk about a this model which is mmm
Colin may be near past architecture or
bacome which is one browser process it's
at the top that kicks
whew multiple of Landru process they
also kicks a plugin process GPU and then
of course utility I am it's important to
mention that this is a this is a
implementation detail there is no speck
how to write over browser there is a
speck way CMS ESS but there's no spec
for how many processes the browser
should use so Firefox might be different
it might be different or might be
different
I'm only choosing this model because I
work for them so it was a lot easier to
answer questions if I had them so
looking at this is very abstract so
let's put it into what you can see in
visual so imagine you're like your old
web browser this part everything outside
of the content that you provide is
called sometimes called chrome of the
application where I believe we're named
chrome come from that browser process
responsibility they have UI thread that
controls UI they have networks where to
get data from network and then the part
that yoko demands web content or the tab
is and reprocessed responsibility if
inside of them have a plugin say flash
and that is controlled by plugging
process and then on top of that
everything visually happening both a the
chrome part of the application and a web
content part of the application is
helped and powered by GPU process cool
yeah so i mentioned that the multiple
lender processes for chrome so what does
that look like well in simple term it
means that each type that you open it's
one process with main thread and worker
thread and you know things like you
might heard from multi in Chris talk so
separating these processes into each tab
gets a little good benefit for this like
you know
we know to top two types don't share a
memory so there is no fear of leaking
and then if you know one tab gets
unresponsible some bug memory week
whatever and then just you know
completely shuts off you just close them
and other drought tabs still works right
I kind of like roughly mentioned that
one tab process but if you have many
many toughs like I do Chrome kind of
starts to be assigning different sites
into same processes so there is
depending on the kind of resource that
your hardware have there is a small
threshold of how many other processes
that they this is reason why if you have
a hundred tabs and then you kill one tub
because it wasn't responsible
all of a sudden fifty other tabs die
right so if all of the tabs were run by
one process then the process and many
threads then if one of them gets busy or
responsible then you have to kill them
all you have to call the browser so
that's the idea of multiple process for
when rendering so let's we now we
covered a how process works on their
knees let's cover how those processes
communicate in order to display whatever
the code that you give it to browsers so
today we're going to look at a very
simple case of loading some website
loading content download an image and
then a little bit of scrolling so I
talked about that the top part of the
browser is controlled by Landru process
so I'm sorry browser process browser
process have a few different threads
like UI thread that controls all the UI
built a network thread that goes out to
get the data from the network and then
store stories thread basically access to
your file access Hey and then I'm sure
there's many more so when you are typing
things into that omnibox that's browser
process responsibility because that's UI
and you already looks at that input
saying like it's this search query or
URL because in comm you can either a
search query and go to a search engine
or you can request a website and in this
case it looks like website so it's a URL
your voicethread calls up a network
thread saying like hey so this
navigation is about the start can you go
get the site and then it works sa thank
you a lot you thought so they go out and
get the data by the way this part is the
very commonly known software engineering
interview question and what what happens
when you are type google.com into a
browser you know go through if you're
like a hot name and DNS and everything I
am skipping all of that just you know
masculine hondo by network thread and
then when the little bit of data comes
back maybe server responds with a
soberly direct so networks the rest this
to you I hate this
you know server says to me direct and I
knew I thoroughly turns same thing I was
like okay then navigate to that Lee
direct them but if the actual content
start to come back the network process
kind of sniff the beginning of the file
by mime type sniffing to make sure the
file that they say they are is the file
they are and you know in case they are
getting image file then you don't they
don't need to lender the page it is a
downloaded quest so they would pass it
on to a storage thread I'm sure and this
is where Safe Browsing check happens so
I'm sure you might have seen who access
one some site and then chrome suddenly
says this might be fishing you might not
want to click through this is where the
check happens like if it is much to the
known malicious content and then the LMS
is yet so but in this case it looks
legit so the network's racist I got what
you requested and browser process
returns like let me get a render process
remember be content web content and the
chrome is a different process so then
at this point on UI thread mine update
to like secure UI shows up and then
you're back and forward button
navigation gets committed the lender
process wake up your wife's recess into
process communication
hey please render this page and then the
process says ok get me that HTML we talk
to network thread and a network thread
forward stuff stream of HTML into a
vendor process Landru takes all of that
do its magic which we will get into and
then returns be event saying hey page
has loaded at this point the spinner
stops spinning and then from browsers
point of view navigation is complete you
have the site at this point if you
decide to type in other URL because as
Java screen
on load handler event handler somebody
types new site again browser UI thread
wakes up and saying like hey did you
want to handle this event and then then
we process looks at it and then like huh
I might have they been hundred for that
and then you know they might block that
navigation or they proceed with
navigation what gets tricky is a
introduction of Service Worker so
Service Worker is a way to write a
caching and banette Makka pakka sea from
your front end code so you write
JavaScript to define which kind of
resource needs to go to cache needs to
go out from the network and you write
your code and then you ship it with your
application this is your Java square
which means it lives on the lander
process but the navigation is handled by
a browser process so the when site is
requested a browser process or the UI
thread checks for known service worker
scope so the browser process have a left
France to a known installed
scope basically a domain of the site and
then checks for it and now you see oh
there
it is a scope serviceworker is installed
so in this case browser process have to
wake up the render process asking hey
you need to align your serviceworker
code and then the process do that and
then turns out lando process wanted to
get a fresh content back so they say
actually the me like please give me
about lee service from the freshly
network and your wife's racist here we
go get that to network process you might
see this round trip is unnecessary these
like possibly making it 0 and this is
reason why sometimes you see article
about like serviceworker startup time
problem there is a proposed both there
is a new feature that is coming into
browser called navigation preload which
basically starting the network request
while they were checking with
serviceworker my teammate Jake or wrote
a great introduction and how to order
call so if you're curious check that out
so now moving on to an under process
where we learn the process have a walk
with rest that you've might heard of
from the beginning talk before me and
they also have compositor thread and
lustrous thread that we will go and to
get into but the make oh I need to
purchase this day that this part is
where when people talk about website
performance goes in so there are so many
details in-depth knowledge many many
many articles even within my team's own
documentation site there is like
hundreds of them so if you're curious of
any of that bit I recommend you to go
check that out and just to make sure
that I'm not just plugging my team
Mozilla has nearly great blog posts
especially with the release of serve
servo and web blender their new engine
especially when Clark has been writing a
lot of great explanation
WebKit blog in between daily beast notes
they also writes amazing documentation
about how internal browser works so if
you're curious about any of this from
this talk I highly recommend check that
out so under process last time we talked
about you know the feed coming in
but the blender process especially main
threads job is to get the data and turn
them into something that's this variable
on the screen so how does that work the
first step is loading and parsing as you
sew they start receiving a stream and
they start leading them from the top to
the bottom and then if the browser the
main thread sees that the link or image
your script that needs to get out to get
it they send the request to the network
thread in browser process together but
result of this process parsing is a Dom
tree that we all know this is a browsers
internal representation of the site as
well as a API another position to ask
JavaScript developer interact with via
JavaScript so in this process if a main
thread is a JavaScript then they need to
pause the parsing and then they need to
get the JavaScript don't know them parse
them execute them and then once
everything is done they can go back to
the list of HTML because javascript can
modify dong so you know am I do a little
bit of HTML and you're feeling good and
then like brow JavaScript comes in and
document light everything that's
possibility so they need to stop that's
this is why a lot of like a kind of
water wisdom about I could put the
JavaScript at the bottom comes from and
then you know modern browsers or more on
web api is has been introducing a lot of
ways to hint to the browser how to treat
those things so if you were sure that
your JavaScript code is now going to
interact with Dom then you can put a
single tree view because that's not
gonna block a evander if you're curious
about those resource priority my
teammate what about those on the same
site that I'd be showing so now that the
dome is there the only Dom is not gonna
construct a website they need style so
the LED CSS and then they curricula it's
what's called a computed style
it's basically
matching of what kind of CSS is applied
to this one given domnode you can see
those in a depth was ha
you see oops you see their computer part
that's what you were seeing the computed
style and once that's done is it
possible to render the page not really I
mean I'm looking at it there is a paper
on top of that paper there's a phone I
can't really describe how it is a placed
or it is so they need to figure out
layout the geometry of the page so the
main thread goes through like you know
oh and the layout is tricky like even
with a simple website like this they
need to figure out where the line blake
is going to be and if they line break on
that point then the top of the box
expands which means the subsequent box
all moves down so there is a vertical
writing on the CSS there is a float and
flex and layout is quite complicated
tasks but they work through that and
then creates what's called layer tree
it's important to note that layer tree
is not equal to dom tree sometimes looks
like it's the same but they all make use
of all the things that's going to be on
the screen so they omit the things like
display now and they add things that's
not in the dom like a pseudo content
from CSS so then it's time to paint
because we have geometry and what's in
them and style of them you might think
that you can pay draw the picture
already but if i'm having this like
human fax machine game is like Sue's
who's my friend sitting in front of me i
can't still can't media just explain
what exactly i am saying in front of me
because of the index and all of the
complicated CSS stuff so if i go through
this by dumb order then i would paint a
header and then next is div and the next
is another div but then there's a d'
index so this is totally messed up
so the
need to figure out exactly how to paint
the page and that process is called
paint they go through the layout tree
and then create what's called a paint Li
course and it's kind of like if you look
at used a canvas API then it's similar
to that you just like have a do this do
that do this to the create the page it's
really important to note that in each
steps the input is from the previous
step so if you mess something up in the
middle of this pixel pipeline then all
of the subsequent trees and data
structures needs to be regenerated if
it's like at the end of their maybe it's
okay but if you do a deep in the lending
process then you know there's a lot of
computation to be done and if you were
doing this kind of thing for your
animation say then you know you're in
problem because our display refreshes
sixteen sixty times a second so you need
to make sure that all the calculation is
catching up to that cadence so you might
be feeling good but then oh you missed a
frame and page chunks or you know am I
feeling good you have like a tiny change
is going in but then keep in mind this
is main thread so it's also hungry in
your JavaScript code and your JavaScript
code is start to throw a heavy
computation thing and then you make a
frame and pin chunks there's a way to
get that timing by calling
requestanimationframe and there's a way
to like divide your heavy JavaScript
tasks so that it doesn't block
calendaring there is heavily documented
on optimizing JavaScript execution
documentation so now that we have all of
the draw orders and everything maybe
it's time to draw or last revised the
page how would you do that well you
might go through naive way like okay I
know the viewport I know the layout I
know how to paint those layout so I'm
gonna lay them up if person's clothes
then I'm gonna fill in the list and if
the UI moves like you know the menu bar
slides
something I'm gonna invalidate that
changed apart and nearly drawn them
again but you can see this kids kind of
like a lot of work if you were trying to
do a 60 frames per second so a modern
browser have a way to do this a little
more and efficiently called a composite
so the idea of composite is that they're
going to divide all of your elements
into layers like Photoshop layers and
they'll a stir them all together that's
why it's already last Erised image so
all the browser has to do is moving and
layering them
so changing the scrolling doesn't matter
moving the things that is already in one
layer as a murderer walk smoothly so
here's a video of you can check this
layer on your dev tool so here's a video
of application that I made which is
visualizing your image input as a new
fabric you can see there are two layers
as I move them you can see that layer
box is moving I am going to soon turn on
the paint in flashing which basically is
a hint see to see which part of the
lesion of the page is painted oh it's
just it is a green paint happen so there
might be some kind of performance
problem that I have but you can see I
move all of my pictures and no paint is
happening it's already last Royce and
it's just moving so that's the composite
in order to do this the browser go
through a layer tree to create a layer
tree and once that layer tree is created
they can composite sometimes you might
find parts of your application that you
think is a layer might not get layer in
that case you can hint to the browser
hey this will change and then bake we're
there for you for the world change and
it's tempting to they're all the things
because it's gonna be plea bastard and
it's just moving them but that man is
old in a another performance junk so
it's always important to measure your
performance runtime performance before
deciding how to use those attributes so
now that all of the trees
paint order is in main thread' calls up
a compositor threat which is specialized
to Honduran dis compositing they commit
that data and say goal display this page
so then compositor thread try to Laster
the page but as you can see the page is
now bigger it's not just beautiful so
they have a mechanism to divide that up
into tile and each of the tile is last
rise using Laster thread what the last
of thread is doing is that getting the
small quad of the page making into a GPU
texture map and put it into GPU memory
also keeping the love friends in a
compositor thread so compositor spread
also have a idea of where the viewport
is so they might schedules the around
the viewport earlier than the one on the
bottom so they are a little more
sophisticated but now you have all of
the draw was compositor thread composite
the page and then create what's called a
compositor frame this is the frame of
your application that you're showing
this one gets sent to a browser process
your IPC same vendor this and browser
process UI process might add another
composite frame you know to display the
UI part of the thing and then sent it to
GPU if the screw comes in remember the
school input comes in the UI thread says
hey there is inter compositor thread
goes no problem I know how to layer
these things so they create another
compositor frame send it to GPU and you
know small screwing because the most
important part is that a compositor
surrett could handle all of this they
didn't need to bother a main thread they
didn't junk the page so but sometimes
you might have this kind of application
where you want to like you know clip the
only horizontal scroll to one region and
you might add other event listener and
and prevent default and then kind of
trying to force the scroll well that
event handler lives in the main thread
in JavaScript so how does dart handled
so compositor thread
when their last raising and compositing
them they mark that part as a known fast
goal of Allegiant which basically means
that if an even happens on this point
then tell me and then I need to ask my
main threat pause the scroll they say
hey you need something maybe I might say
yeah there is event handler so I'm gonna
block that default move right but there
is a common technique in JavaScript
which is event delegation you put it one
event listener on the top or the big
lesion of it and then you check which of
the target it is in this case it's a
problem everything becomes known fast
scrollable legion and compositors
threader is basically just dispatching
the message to main threat like you need
it like even though main threat actually
didn't need those part they need to ask
to them so as a web developer it's a big
chunk so as a web developer we can put a
passive true options and that makes you
Legion not read basically what it means
is that I still want to hear about the
event on the main threat but you can go
ahead and start scrolling if you want to
and there is a CSS attribute like touch
action panics which basically you don't
need to write any JavaScript logic to
prevent default and then clip it to
whatever the gesture that you want just
write a CSS and browser takes care for
you so those things also document it on
our side if you want to check that out
so hopefully this didn't overwhelm you
with like so many things I need to know
well there is a little bit of tools to
help you when you are trying to develop
so one is lighthouse lighthouse is a
plug-in also tool that lives within the
chrome developer tool if you go open the
audits tab they run the audit over your
site and then tells you the score and a
lot of people cares about the score and
getting hundred but what I find more
interesting is a explanation of each
audit
and when I started at this team home
develop operations first thing I did was
going through all of the audit to learn
what browser cares about as a
performance or any other business area
other thing that's coming to the
platform is a feature policy so future
potty is like a content security policy
but for your feature so you put a little
bit of a snippet in your header then it
will block the feature so you might have
things like fast animation feature
policy where every CSS animation that is
not performing it's blocked there is a
feature policy demos up comm that has
all of the try and eller type of thing
and this is super this is very new and
it's really interesting to see what kind
of feature policies proposed because it
tells what kind of performance problems
what kind of feature problem that the
web developer and browser engineers are
having so hopefully through this you
might thought that oh I already knew
that you are on the behind the side of
the browser I was the front side if you
are like me who is like this is
interesting but I don't know where to
start I recommend just building
applications it doesn't have to be to do
MVC it doesn't have to be Hakone use
clone you can pick whatever the thing
you want to do I like knitting so for
three years since last year's comes I
made more than five I'm sure I'm
forgetting knitting related application
which all of them have idea of compilers
a bit operations UI transform smooth
scrolling all of it and like by the time
the fifth one knitter if I this is the
only one that I can proudly say to my
friend hey use this sauce vacation it's
actually kind of cool so it takes time
it's really frustrating but I highly
recommend learning them and if you
didn't get anything from it I hope this
image of q-thruster now engrave into
your brain and you think about them
every time you open a browser this has
been me Marco that's my twitter handle
this slide is super eye
in heavy I am planning on publishing
static version later and all of the
reference I mean I counted this morning
I had a 48 tabs of resources to us so
dough will be coming soon if you took
any of the pictures or you want to use
the slice later I consider all of my
drawing to be CC by NC s a 4.0 whatever
that was I forgot I decided that was the
license I'm going to use so if you use
them in your talk or education no blog
or whatever do they mean oh please use
away thank you very much
[Applause]